I have been anxiously awaiting this guy
I haven't heard these tapes I heard
they're pretty good this is the guy
who's been calling our office all last
week and pranking Gary
making scam calls on him very good he's
been very good at yeah
funny huh I actually was amused by him
and here he is here's the guy hey hey
dude how you doing
take a seat
so do you this is the guy yeah
give the microphone guys like it's dr.
Walker yeah your stockbroker yeah and
what happened you just like sitting
around the office had some free time on
your hand and you well every day when we
have our breakfast we're really supposed
to be on the phones but I listen to you
right and I said let me call it powered
use an alias to get on the show right so
one day I'm personal friends with a
Beastie Boys and I have I know the
Beastie Boys that's how it all started
right I said it was MCA and then Garry
kept screwing to me and call me a jerk
into a hole you want Beastie Boys
groupie yeah
Beastie Boys goofy I guess you could say
that how old are you you submit the
young guy 26 26 and what is it you have
like a fawful we fascination well look
at them of course with a mustache you're
me and your teeth are pretty stained as
well you don't have a mustache Gary no
but I mean yeah one line grew and I kept
them listen what's wrong with them like
mine used to be but he's got nice teeth
outside his mouth does you have wood and
eyeballs to come on a little bit on the
pumpkin side but they're all right those
are the nicest teeth they ever came
across at least you can't play hide and
seek in my mouth right you're saying
that his teeth are as bad as yours yeah
Gary you should be looking at him from
where I'm looking at them there's no way
that you Artie than his teeth look
similar put an African tribe under those
teeth so what happened you started
making some phony phone calls and you
tape that was this Gary Burmese like
losing I don't think I want the Beastie
Boys on the Howard Stern Show I'm like
what because I'm the big no no I said to
the guy listen even if you were the guy
from the Beastie Boys which I'm sitting
here arguing with this guy for 10
minutes yeah right yeah we'd even want
you on you know just one other guy right
yeah one other guy Beastie Boy so I say
to Gary they have the number one album
that have you heard and guys like oh
yeah really what and I'm like it'll
communication I go you have your head
shoved so far up your butt you don't
even know if you're coming to going
that's when he hung up on me right you
know what's so funny I all did I just
did it to get through to you of course
you know right any way to get through to
you guy said let me use the Beastie Boys
because and Gary said to me you know
what that was pretty smart because you
used a low-key guy
something let me hear your work okay so
this is you walling so what's the first
one what slow this is me getting back to
guy I'm like you know what now I'm gonna
set him up and I'm gonna just burn them
okay are you being on this course phone
call I am a fake name named Steve Ryan
from the New York Post okay all right
all right here is our man this is Sally
I just wanted a quick quote from you
what would you consider the three
essential characteristics that make up
good radio after the show okay who
should I ask for hey Gary you know what
let me give you my extension here okay
just when you asked for me
yeah just tell the secretary that you're
a horse tooth jackass what's his second
call my second call I was a juror on the
OJ Simpson trial oh good okay here we go
yes and by the way I may add that this
was back to back with the Steve Ryan
phone call excellent this is on the same
day right after right after this is Sal
king of old Gary pranks that's right
you see me
[Music]
[Applause]
the second individual removed because I
was accused of cornering Simpson oh that
was right back to back yeah it was
alright then what's what's your next
call my next call the umpire died from
of the Cincinnati Reds okay so I called
up and said let me be Ron Gant so
they'll just pass it to Gary Ron Gant is
a player for the I think the rest
roadkill I don't even know who Ron Gant
is I couldn't give a crap but anyway I
say Ron Gant and I set him up this is
great why is this so funny Robi that
everyone's into it all right here we go
here's Sal king of all Gary pranks
[Laughter]
makeup shirts htj and Sal what's the
last one you got here for last one I am
cliff well this is what happen I try to
go you know try to get Gary this is it
everybody knew who I was and a friend of
mine Jeff who I work with Jeff Lombardi
says say you cliff Bernstein from Q
prime management Gary knows him
personally I'm sure right so I made like
I was booking Metallica Ron let him in
did I get him in in the morning for the
show
great and Gary as usual fell right into
knowledge day there we go heavy hitter
right close on the phone I want to know
what's going on right well let's hear
what happens today
[Music]
that's great I mean what can we do
little one yeah absolutely
April 15 yep listen wait a second what's
your partner's name it's cool Horsetooth
jackass all right Sal listen to me can
he still crank Gary oh yeah now he's
completely encouraged gonna be a way of
life for Sal get some new clients now at
the firm all right great okay that's Sal
everyone king of all Gary goofs whatever
you want to call him Horsetooth jackass
you